and also the the workers in america
every time you go to like let's say
7-eleven yeah first of all you got like
a bunch of druggy guys over there like
right well you call them homeless people
or something
yeah
i mean i guess i don't know
i don't know what the politically
correct term for that is but i'm pretty
sure druggy guy is from the political
collector
i mean
sketchy yeah
sketchy sass especially in new york like
every time i leave at like
three a.m in the morning right i'll
always get pursued
by by uh you know yeah that sounds like
a panhandler yeah yeah and then they'll
follow you into the store
and
and then they you know i'm like well i
would give you money but if i gave you
money that means i would have to give
one dollar
like no i'd have to give like 50 bucks
every day because you literally get
begged right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
i'm like
i don't know is is this non-stop right
right right anyway so the uh the gas
station starts yeah man go back to japan
right yeah also by the way the workers
in 7-eleven or wherever they are they
look like they don't want to be there
they just want to they they look sad
well in america or japan in america oh
okay
yeah i mean it's pretty chill because
you're just like you going i don't think
you're paid enough to like also also
then have to pretend to be happy about
it like i mean to be fair it's kind of
the same way in japan as well
they pretend to be yeah
no it's so different yeah actually i
watched so much that show though yeah
yeah yeah sometimes yeah sometimes
yeah yeah sometimes well that was one
time actually like i think this happened
like three when i just came to japan i
went to 7-eleven i went to get like a
beer like strong zero or whatever and
then it wasn't scanning the guy like ran
you like ran because it wasn't skinny
you ran through the fridge and then he
ran back
like comment share
this way subscribe that's the thing
though right like the japan's like
standard for customer service is so
insanely high that there is probably
like some [ __ ] japanese guy or girl
out there who would complain being like
come on hurry up
yeah you know it makes me sad like a
little bit but at the same time i get
good service yeah yeah yeah yeah right
yeah
i'd be scared
sometimes the service is so good that
it's like imposing i'm just like you
don't get like you don't need i don't
need the service to be this good bro you
can chill you know sometimes i do it so
good that like next time you go to like
the same place like when you go to
ryokan right yeah sometimes when they
like when you get there they welcome you
like you're a king dude yeah that's what
i'm saying
they take your bags they're like looking
after you and then other times you'll go
to another royal can you be like you'll
be like i hope they do it but i won't
expect it and then you get disappointed
that they're like what are you on
yeah when you do when you find that one
guy that like doesn't care you're just
like what is this like
yeah yeah yeah yeah it like completely
like warps your like perspective about
it even though like you go anywhere else
in america and it's like it's just
normal it's normal yeah it's normal
right yeah
yeah it's just like it's it's like
warped my perception of you know what is
what i find is good service and what
even like what even stands out to me
because i remember like i was like
because i was in england last week i
remember just like going to a normal
restaurant you know
and uh it was such a small thing because
i was so used to just like the japanese
service being like as polite and as you
know soft as they can so i remember it
was just like it was i went to a
restaurant and then i asked for the bill
right and it was just such a small thing
uh they slammed it down on the table and
said uh it's a
they slammed down the team and said 50
pounds
i was like oh that's that's that was a
bit aggressive like you know what i mean
it was it was like because like it it
surprised me because i was so used to
like you know japanese japanese service
just like bringing it to you
like 50 pounds
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly right
exactly right i didn't even get a please
you know or something or you know well
thank you
50 pounds
it's quite odd even for the uk to be
fair really really i don't know because
i've i've it's been so long since i've
been to the uk that i'm just like am i
an [ __ ] for thinking that was a bit
aggressive they don't say the price out
loud right am i crazy oh they're kind of
just like here's the let me just give it
to you yeah well it's interesting they
bring the bill to you in the uk but in
japan i noticed you always have to go up
to there well so it depends on the
restaurant differently
i haven't been to a single one where
they gave you the bill for some reason
sometimes you have to pay at the table
so they bring you the bill normally the
fancier it is or the more european it's
trying to be you pay the team yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah then if it's if it's just
like what if it's like a japanese story
i'm waiting for that moment bro
yeah has it happened yet i'll i'll take
you too yeah yeah yeah i know all places
best italian food in here yeah like
normally if it's uh if it's japanese
food then you'll pay it like the till
but if you go to like a more westernized
place then it is they try to like i
guess embrace foreign culture it's fine
some of the restaurants will actually
have like a thing that says pay at the
table yeah yeah obviously well if they
want to embrace foreign culture they
should do tips i'm just kidding
i wish they did
honestly like
you don't want tips no but for how good
the service yeah i mean sometimes i
don't know
american tips i don't want twenty
percent of the [ __ ] bills yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] phone we don't eat out as
much i don't blame them i noticed the
the grocery store if you live in the
city the grocery store is like more
expensive than eating out which is like
yeah japan is like one of the rare
countries where eating out is actually
cheaper yeah it's so weird last time we
said that we got some people who are
like oh you said that's not true at all
you can you well if you live in a city i
guess
certain things are cheaper certain
things are more expensive like obviously
if you go to you know size here and get
a pasta you get like this much for like
300 yen then yeah you should make your
own pasta but that's like pasta like if
you want a ramen you can't make your own
ramen for at home yeah it's going to be
like so many ingredients the melons
like 300 why
have you tried one of them like this and
it's 300 what because some guy like rubs
it for hours he's just like what do you
mean haven't you tried one of them
no no no no no no i'm just i'm just
asking have you tried it
um it's not nothing it's it's not worth
it it's not worth it no because i
actually saw like i actually saw a
documentary on this on like why the
melons in japan are so expensive
yeah they do it's like a very like
japanese culture they wear so like they
only pick the cream of the crop every
melon is like grated and like it's
perfect it's not just like the taste
it's like a look it's the look it's like
the like the crinkling on the side as
well that gets great as well for like
look and aesthetic and i'm just like i
do not give a [ __ ]
i'm just like is it just kind of sweet
okay that's cool it's because in japan
giving fruit is like the utmost like it
yeah it's a flex for like gift giving
that's like uh lobsters they used to be
like uh slavery food right like peasant
food yeah yeah now they're like yeah a
delicacy here all right fruit is the
same way
but yeah like because in japan it's like
gift giving such a huge thing and like
giving fruit to someone is like oh [ __ ]
you really care for me yeah so that's
why they make it expensive it won't work
on us right well it won't work on us
yeah just like just give me a [ __ ]
granny smoothie i'll be good you know
yeah go to the grocery store buy me a
cheaper grape yeah exactly like you
spend how much on this watermelon yeah
yeah because like i i've noticed that
about i guess like the japanese artisan
culture which i guess i'm going to call
it which is like one thing i can say
about
japan is that if you're a craft
craftsman you put like your [ __ ]
heart and soul into whatever you're
making right i mean that's why japan has
like such a high standards for so many
things right and you know you you know
you see this with for example with you
know like japanese tools like japanese
knives for example you see like
documentaries about you know people who
have like inherited their [ __ ] grand
great great grandfather's like [ __ ]
blacksmith or something yeah generation
six yeah yeah every single one of those
documentaries is the same yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then they'll be like oh what
makes what makes your uh salt so special
and then they'll go on about the family
recipe and yeah how
[Music]
this has been passed down through the
knowledge of like [ __ ] five different
generations great grandfather yeah yeah
yeah just made nine and then it's like
it's like the same way with the melons
for example where you look at the melon
farms and it's like you know massage it
yeah they literally massage it
they're just a dude who's just like
yeah i thought you were joking no no no
no no they actually do that yeah they're
like they're robbing a baby yeah yeah
yeah and like i you know i respect the
fact that they have like such pride with
their work and their craft but there's a
point when i'm just gonna like be like
it's just a melon you know
i'm sorry i'm sorry it is it's really
cool and like i have like so much
respect for people who do that kind of
stuff but like i'm not always going to
buy into it yeah yeah
there are some things where i'm just
like you know there are some tools where
i'm just like yes this definitely does
need the care and attention and the
knowledge of like years of work and
sometimes i'm just like i mean it's
slightly sweeter you know it's a
slightly sweet strawberry is it worth us
that much i don't oh i don't know i
don't know it just doesn't work in other
countries yeah it doesn't it reminds me
of like maylene when she's like teach
eggs for like eight dollars eight
dollars
is the person that buys into it
yeah yeah yeah she made emily buy it and
she's like
emily got ready and she's like i'll try
it's like mainly said it's like eight
dollar eggs and it's like tastes like
rich and stuff i say i'm like
tastes like an egg
i'm sorry if the melons [ __ ] ready to
eat i don't need like tanaka center
massage yeah yeah i'll just eat it
i'll just i'll eat it like i don't i
don't i don't know to me it's just like
i don't know this obsessive nature of
like
the fruit and things have to be perfect
and it's like in the uk as well we used
to like i think uh
throw away like carrots or stuff that
weren't like the right shape yeah i
wouldn't buy them yeah just [ __ ] give
it to them like i wouldn't mind so much
if there at least was like a cheapo
option you know because like yeah you
know because because i if it feels like
you know i'm fine if i want to like you
know treat myself and i know like i'm
going to buy a fruit that is like a
hundred percent of the time [ __ ] a
grade you know like you know sometimes
like you buy a pack of strawberries in
the uk and it's like it's like
strawberry gacha sometimes it's like a
little bit sour sometimes you get that
perfectly sweet one but you know it's
like in japan every strawberry you buy
is like that sweet like that sweet one
every single time
but i do want to the option to just be
like just give me a [ __ ] cheap
give me the [ __ ] pack that i just want
to like stuff myself literally like pay
to win it is oh my gosh
it's like you are paying so that you
guarantee every strawberry is going to
be an ssr yeah yeah oh my [ __ ] god
it's just like why did they put like
fruit behind a paywall like
all
the foods to like put behind the paywall
yeah like the other thing i wouldn't
mind either is like you know say for
example if it's like knives right or
like tools or something that makes sense
that shit's gonna last you for a long
time right because like there's quality
to it yeah i can finish a packet of
strawberries in like five minutes you
know so it's like oh cool so the thing i
just spent five minutes on that costs
200 yeah yeah yeah like a parody
documentary of like a flaming hot cheeto
like a premium version being made this
isn't just any flavor like hand dust it
like spread the dust on them this is
made by chester cheetah himself
they like hand fry every single cheeto
before like dusting it with like [ __ ]
and then like massage it
like it's like infused with like fairy
dust or some [ __ ] like that